it's been a while but we're back with
some injustice to gameplay this time
it's sub-zero being shown off in nether
realms live stream and if you haven't
picked the game up yet you can always
check out our review on GameSpot calm
right off you can see is down to is
awesome it's a great anti-air attack
Barry's been very high up it's very fast
so yeah look at that so going through
the air is not a good idea then he has a
really good jump attack he uses a sword
and you can go in so there's kind of a
basic attacks and then um he has a lot
of his MKX moves like his 4 2 is back
and it still goes into this throw and
has really good range like you can see
it kind of hits me to start around or
you can go into a combo of it hits and
he has 1/1 which is uh his Chinese ninja
warrior strong yeah with this heart so
cold the new thing about this is though
this lasted is actually overhead so
that's going to lead to some mix ups
like you can do 101 ice ball or civil
mix-up would be one one one one slide
you kind of spoiled it that we he has a
slide an ice ball well I think we don't
know what knew he was gonna have slide
and ice ball and then this could be
tricky if you have the flown out no fall
McClung then he can get a combo so
you're thinking you know the slide is
not much reward you have the clone out
all of a sudden that's a great 50/50
it's unsafe but he's gonna get good
damage and throw you into the clump okay
I talked through some of those
individually though you're doing setups
really early why are you doing bro I
just wanted to talk about why didn't go
through the throw we haven't gone on a
lot of the stuff you've been spit a
while since it's been a while back on
track so he's also got pretty obvious
which is a pop up he doesn't get like a
full combo elicits in the corner but
it's pretty good it's a good Punisher
and then his best new move is his 3/3
which is a knee it's a very fast been
attack
I love the animation for that yeah it
looks really cool and that's like a
great Punisher or maybe like you hit
with the down wand and you want to go no
pressure it's you can never go wrong
with a really good range fast men
attacking and that's what he's got
fabulous he's off with his forward to
his back but unlike him kicks he
actually slides forward you can actually
see
that he creates an icicle on the ground
and slides forward yeah so it's very
fast and has a ton of range like this is
past the start of the round and it will
actually connect so he can like go into
a clown or going to a nice blast or just
complete the string it is a high so the
opponent can duck it but then that's
what this is for or this is for it if
you have them conditioned to stand you
can go for it it's really really good
range all right you want all you want to
do is throw throw I love that I love his
throw as well lamb oh that's great
all right specialist all right so ice
falls back with a big change it does not
freeze normally it just does a chunk
alive you have to meet her burn now that
which makes a lot of sense in a way this
game works typically happen that hold
has the same the same thing right
typically an injustice you have to use a
power meter to combos so that's why it's
like that way now the nice thing is if
you do me Roberta it actually flows
through other projectiles oh oh come on
this will never work
well our one two three I count it out
dude one two three simple so one of the
best things since MK 1 about the ice
blast is it's great for projectile
training I do mine fireball you do yours
mine's gonna go through you hit me but I
get a combo so I win every trade right
sure and if he uses a parameter he still
has that option so the opponent's gonna
have to be super super careful when he's
got a bar on me dirty one students then
of course slide his back this time it
actually sends them flipping the other
way so again like I showed earlier you
can get a cloth and if he exit you gets
additional damage and it also looks
really awesome our meter burns it a lot
of people in the chat are complaining
that it doesn't freeze on non meter burn
that would make him the best character
in the game yeah it's definitely
something you'll have to get used to but
I think everyone be fine with it
once you get used to it it's just
scorpions fear Allah say that like even
a meter greensburg in spear his crime in
sea powers are actually weakened when he
enters the multi-verse
it makes sense right since he's part
Outworld him that's like where you know
his heritage is it actually gets weaker
the further away from out role
yes right so that's that's Steve's fake
lore minute yeah that's more I just made
up I loved it I thought it was cool I
guess it's game if it's on the
watchtower it's canon it is now ken I
don't know if I have the authority to
make Canada well too late now wait all
right you've just gotten that
responsibilities there you go
so um he also has his first bag and this
is just a good combo ender and but
what's new is the meter burn you'll
actually go across the screen with his
shoulder very reminiscent of the Mortal
Kombat Deadly Alliance cold shoulder I
love it and this is actually
advantageous unblocked meaning it's safe
and Sub Zero actually recovers a
performance so it's it's a good way to
get in or to end your combos like your
block strings like they're gonna block
and you're safe or you know if they
block it he's far away you can go for a
clone and it's gonna be harder from the
punish so it's it's really one of those
moves that you can't go wrong into your
string and then ice hammer is a very
fast overhead attack when he jumps you
can actually do it really low to the
ground and then meter burn is new
bee-bop's you and this is also safe on
block little Bobby Larew yeah so you
know it's not huge damage but it's it's
very safe on block so that's a good
thing you can mix about it's very hard
anti-air and then once they're used to
dealing with that then you can do your
jump ends and lastly his command rep and
this is a true command grab if they're
blocking Jill gets hit throw and on
normal hitting knocks him down he gets
abusive struck and damaged if you meter
burn it it's actually because a combo or
you could use it as a recent you could
end your combos on it Peter Burton
go for like a tutu and then use that
frame advantage that basically they're
staggering and then go for another mix
up so and the combos extend combos start
combos it's a really good multi-purpose
yeah love it let's see the super
character power oh yeah yeah yeah
peel build your character oh okay very
first all right so this character power
is the ice climber its back its back
again it's you know one of those like
identifying moves and you can throw it
which does a big chunk of damage and it
takes up my palm of the screen he
actually can throw it low - and he could
burst it and it'll blow up and he can
kind of use it as a shield so he can
hide behind it do a few ice balls
if the opponent tries to get in you
burst and they're gonna take some damage
or are you gonna sit behind it the whole
time now you'll notice on the UI it's
actually you can sell when it's on
cooldown based there before you just
kind of had to kind of memorize it you
have a visual indicator oh my Kim K X he
can do it in the air again - oops and he
has all the options he can throw the air
one or burst the air one so the air
one's back which I'm super excited about
hi
did your hype go up a level my hype
going up two levels cuz I'm here instead
a nine-man alright but what if I told
you my hot level could be at ten tell me
it could be a ten can it be at ten Steve
Wow beer burn the clone and he actually
gets two different clones and this is
the ultimate defensive shield okay let
me let me try and do some eye lasers
here you go guys here alright alright so
I was having fun um yeah so the opponent
cannot jump
they can't - through it they're gonna
basically have to either hold that try
to counter zone him which he adds this
for or they're gonna have to beat up a
roll and if you're ready for me to burn
roll should even get it started
throws be tinted vulnerable meet upper
throw and Sub Zero will throw them back
out ooh question Steve what can you
throw both of the clones why
Oh - has to be at 11:00 at this point
yeah it's like at 12:00
no two points for each song clone booze
job
that's awesome see you super alright
love it that shot behind his back when
he's just freezing like the ice dam is
that what he's kind of yeah Chinese
ninja warriors don't dad right you're
right that's actually embarrassing is
that more he is a very noble serious
wort with true impact who lives in the
ice mountains of China like he's not in
the pop culture and an Internet called
if that questions to you about this kind
of stuff okay he's gonna look bad
alright alright I'm gonna step back so
anything else about your the base the
base level the release sub-zero I think
um like what do you expect the Sub Zero
he really excels in the corner I think
his game is mostly gonna be playing to
give you the corner taking some risks
using little random slides jump ins and
hoping it in the corner and then it's
party time which is wake up his wake up
is the slide it's fully invincible
so it's invincible it's not a lot of
damage it's punishable but you're gonna
you know good why not yeah yeah it's
it's a variable it goes far you're gonna
get a couple during a match regardless
of how yeah I think they're coming so
and if you're a high-risk player you can
do it if they punish it you could just
do it again I would yeah gonna fly I'll
do it again yeah so I I think like the
last few games he's he's really a
character that's gonna excel in the
corner he's gonna keep you locked down
and he's gonna use moves like it's
easiest for three is fairly fast
it's a venting Tucson block and you
cannot jump this one it's very very
cheap when they're trying to jump so
that's gonna be great in the corner
these sizes back 1/1 which is a low
combo starter he's got a lot of really
good tools and starters yeah absolutely
cool so we should we check out the
different loadout we have a couple today
down a couple we have some pretty cool
stuff actually oh yeah we worked on
these this afternoon I'm excited
so this one's really neat it has the
sort of this the metal sort of yeah mask
thing it's really cool-looking I really
like the color the darker color
alright so this loadout we gave him oh
oh ground freeze its back the the
classic' MK to move it's actually a
block of wood and it does very low
damage me opponent will slip so they're
all kind of really cheap set up so you
can do like you can do it on not down no
don't have to like back the actual way
and another thing they're gonna back
that you can punish that but if you
mirror burn it I'm actually freezing the
ground that's a combo starter
so it's this doubles is like kind of a
trap like gimmicky setup move that like
to create a player's really love and
it's just functions as a compost starter
you just want functionality right so
it's pretty awesome it's a class I'm I'm
super glad to see it back I always love
the ground freeze oh yeah I do they also
mk3 for my favorites so here does it
have a cake there's without a lot of
gear doesn't have its own that does do
you have that choices yes yeah I loved
capes of 0 but if you don't want to Cape
every battle defines you you can really
good yes thank you for mark with
marketing the game for every battle the
fun is that now that was a that's a few
slots of to slaughter that's yes and
that's a to slaughter that's a pretty
powerful move so that's a to slaughter
okay okay would you like to explain what
to slaughter is I I absolutely this
loadout classic ninja outfit when the
red color is so excited this is like a
17 out of 10
yeah oh really cool so what kind of
special moves all right here we gave
them to new ones in the first is a nice
teleport nice and you can go backwards
or you can go behind them it's kind of
reminiscent of what we're Kombat vs. DC
you love them yeah I thought that's
really cool so that's cool then that's
back if you want it to be back and you
know sub-zero
like maybe you're keeping the opponent
out and it's not really effective and
you want
way to get in besides the slide you can
go for this and then I accidentally gave
way the other move you did this type of
that replaces slide it is a clone -
punch which it's about memorable it's
super fast it's a mid attack and then
the meter burn is somehow even cooler
than that it is a clone slot that's so
good so I put a black outfit on I
understood yep yep yeah so he also has
another clone attack that you might have
saw in the trailer a divekick one that
will show you I have to get that
unlocked and see what back to but I have
a feeling it's a dive well I mean
there's a meter burnt version that we
didn't show oh oh
spoilers so yeah this basically improves
his mid-range game and it makes it so
now the vast yeah you right it's the
functionality of the slide but you have
to take the risk to actually go in row
it's really really cool but it does
replace your regular slide so you have
two choice to catch it cool
Oh got one more I think right we do have
an extra special extra special loadout
just because I want to show set right
interesting this cool one oh well okay
um hey do you want to try and beat up
Steve's yeah they should let's do that
okay okay
trim it bro
turnip bro tournament bro yeah there cuz
this is so serious yeah this is it we're
not Assyria the highest possible level
right all right well the chat is blowing
up about what that last guy left they
love that last well the gear live on
they love the gear yeah they're up there
freaking out about it I don't know
interesting all right I'm gonna try and
do my flash which is probably the worst
idea possible plateful yes I did he did
one time then you bopped him yeah so
there was a popping around two bombings
prepare for combat I pick up with duty
calls
people reason masks how could you tell
if he was talking all right all right
all right so far so good now that's a
perfect example of how you don't want to
play it Sub Zero he he think he really
hurts
impatient play the key is patience again
stuff all right so if you ever see Derek
online when sub-zero's release yeah this
is very giftable
we were we were literally saying a while
ago that the clone is the most anti
Derek move ever created oh no I was
totally blocking that that is a lie that
is a lie no see your buttons beep under
the kicks ha ha don't they I don't play
on the flat right the basic like they've
actually actually checked my buttons
yeah I'm sure that's where all of it no
no I look pretty good to me
yeah right in the same right in the
place to post events that's my man yeah
no come on Steve
oh it's getting Bob okay oh no what do
you say okay for like you would give in
there I mean look at this oh yeah you do
baby
yeah plus those good Dan Mazer Danny bro
all right be patient oh wow with a slide
and I'm gonna move that into the world I
can't do anything no in the quarter nope
get back
come on I'm trying back in the corner
here in a lot of trouble
Yolo no no go oh oh that was rude
alright so my plan yesterday
yeah it was uh I probably something
should not have picked left
you always pick flesh I had all day and
then always say I shouldn't think yeah
I've never heard you say I made the
right choice but they like I don't want
to I don't like I Love You Man I don't
want to like talk crap your Flash is no
good
like right